tint the windows on the Range Rover it's
hard dealing with my pain sober but I'm
balling to the games over ice around my
body I'm surrounded by the flame
throwers kill you on camera for you see
me hearing this chain over I Did It For
My City even though half of these
goofies hating my music playing in the
same towns I was moving waiting I used
to put it on a scale like a boxer when
they do the weigh-ins cut all my old
off from having new relations
throughout the nation brought the
dumpers with us got about a bouncer
ain't no thumping with us keep it honest
with yourself you never seen no
like this in your life a hundred
thousand worth of ice I'm in the
trenches tonight and they respect it
cause it's genuine see it in my eyes I
don't really roll them windows down or
hop down and let it fly lettuce music
but I throw it all away for my
pride I talk to life is more than anyone
free all of my gods on God okay